[Applause]
daily cases are skyrocketing and covered
hospitalizations in england are at their
highest since february alarm bells are
ringing that an omicron surge is about
to crash over the already struggling
national health service so if we keep
increasing at that rate of course the
pressures are again mounting and week on
week and when you've got a workforce as
i've said that's already absent
50 000 nurses and many more
self-isolating then of course the
pressures are building and building and
building so what will it be like in
january
contingency plans are being put in place
to cope if existing hospital capacity
becomes overwhelmed with new temporary
wards built to house patients
eight temporary surge hubs are being
built at hospitals around the country
each one with a capacity of 100 beds
more sites are being planned for an
extra four thousand beds if needed it
hopes that none of this will ever be
used but it's there just in case
london is preparing for new year's eve
but with the big fireworks display
cancelled for a second year and omicron
keeping people indoors celebrations will
be much reduced
on the continents new infection records
are beaten almost daily italy logged 126
000 on thursday up from wednesday's 98
000 testing centers are becoming
overwhelmed and tempers are fraying
i've been queuing since 9 30 a.m i'm
exhausted it was madness to book in it
took me two days to be able to book in
the only available spots were outside
central rome
i came here and i spent five hours in
line five hours
greece has brought forward new
restrictions which had been planned for
early january new year's eve aside bars
nightclubs and restaurants will be
forced to close at midnight with no
standing customers and no music there's
dismay in the hospitality sector
certainly for us in the restaurant
sector it is a disaster that's the key
word here but on the other hand you
can't go against the health situation i
can't say i want to stay open and work
while people are dying greece italy and
the uk have all seen record numbers of
cases in recent days and it's likely
there are more records to come rory
challen's al jazeera london